Authoritarians are those who favor enforcing strict obedience to authority,...
...especially that of the government,...
...at the expense of personal freedom.
It's pretty obvious when one is around,...
...and is related to words like dictator, despot, draconian or tyrant.
But why would anyone elect an authoritarian government?
Researcher Erich Fromm hypothesized people's authoritarian voting...
...stems from feelings of insecurity.
Hitler was elected, in part, because of German fear of communism,...
...and, according to researchers,...
...when people are "faced with an uncertain world and lack of direction,..."
"...they will escape from freedom," into security.
Essentially, if a group of people feel their economic stability is in jeopardy,...
....their safety is threatened in some way,...
...or their country is no longer their own for some reason,...
...then they may vote for an authoritarian regime...
...who they believe can restore uniformity and security, and punish difference.